مساء الخير وكل عام وانتم بخير وطبعا
مشاهدين مساء العربيه بالف خير طبعا
المسلسل احدث جدل كبير لاسباب عديده ومن
الحلقه الاولى كان هنالك تقريبا اربع او
خمس مشاهد اظهرها المسلسل تتحدث عن الفرد
العراقي وعن المراه العراقيه هذه
المشاهدين التي احدثت جدل خاصه وان احداث
المسلسل تتحدث عن ثمانينات القرن الماضي
وفي ثمانينات القرن الماضي في لندن كانت
الجاليه العراقيه يعني ليست بهذا الشكل
الذي يظهره المسلسل لان المراه العراقيه
تعمل كخادمه او ان هنالك رجل عراقي يعمل
خادم لدى يعني يعني لدى اناس من الجاريه
الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
من شهر رمضان والطبقه الواحده تتالف من 30
بيضه هذه كانت تقريبا سخريه الشارع
العراقي بهذا الشان وهذه السله لم توزع
حتى الان يعني حتى هذه اليوم الرابع
تقريبا من رمضان لم توزع هذه السله على كل
المناطق في بغداد والمحافظات فهناك الكثير
من المناطق يعني لم تحصل على هذه السله
الغذائيه وهذا الامر يعني تعود عليه
العراقيون في تقريبا السنوات الماضيه ايضا
كان هنالك عهود ووعود من الحكومه العراقيه
بصرف سله غذائيه استثنائيه لكن للاسف
انتهى رمضان ولما يحصل اغلب لم تحصل اغلب
المناطق في بغداد والمحافظات على هذه
السله انا عندي احلى بيضه سهام
شكرا جزيلا من بغداد مراسل العربيه زينب
المش نادين كل مره تجيب العيد شكرا لك يا
زينب